in drawing the slope field for the
differential equation the derivative of
Y with respect to X is equal to y -2 X I
would place short line segments at
select points on the XY plane complete
the sentences at the point negative 1
comma 1 I would draw a short segment of
slope blank and like always pause this
video and see if you can fill out these
three blanks well when your the short
segments that you're trying to draw to
construct this slope field you figure
out their slope based on the
differential equation so you're saying
when X is equal to negative 1 and Y is
equal to 1 what is the derivative of Y
with respect to X and that's what this
differential equation tells us so for
this first case the derivative of Y with
respect to X is going to be equal to Y
which is 1 minus 2 times X X is negative
1 so this is going to be negative 2 but
you're subtracting it so it's going to
be plus 2 so the derivative of Y with
respect to X at this point is going to
be 3 so I would draw a short line
segment or a short segment of slope 3
and we keep going at the point 0 comma 2
well let's see when x is 0 and Y is 2
the derivative of Y with respect to X is
going to be equal to Y which is 2 minus
2 times 0 well that's just going to be 2
and then last but not least for this
third point the derivative of Y with
respect to X is going to be equal to Y
which is 3 minus 2 times X X here is 2 2
times 2 3 minus 4 is equal to 4 3 minus
3 minus 4 is equal to negative 1 and
that's all that problem asks us to do
now if we actually had to do it it would
look something like I'll try to draw it
real fast so let's see make sure I can
go to let make sure have space for all
of these points here so so that's my my
coordinate axes
and I want to get the point 0 comma 2 so
that's 0 comma 2 actually I want to go
all the way to 2 comma 3 so let me get
some space here so 1 2 3 and then 1 2 3
and then we have to go negative 1 comma
1 so you might go we might go right over
here and so for this first one and this
exercise isn't asking us to do it but
I'm just making it very clear how we
would construct the slope field so the
point negative 1 comma 1 negative 1
comma 1 a sort segment of slope 3 so
slope 3 would look something like
something like that then at the point at
the point 0 comma 2 a slope of 2 0 comma
2 the slope is going to be 2 which looks
something like that and then at the
point 2 comma 3 at 2 comma 3 a short
segment of slope negative 1 so 2 comma 3
a slope a segment of slope negative 1 it
would look something like that
and you would keep doing this at more
and more points if you had a computer to
do it that's what the computer would do
and you would draw these sorts line
segments to indicate what the derivative
is at those points and you get a sense
of the solution space for that
differential equation